all six numbers for the drawing tonight
you'd win about 560 million dollars and
Heather that is still quite a bit of
money I think it'll do pretty well and
my yeah do all right I gotta get it
all right tomorrow the WNBA All-Star
game comes right here to Las Vegas the
best of the best are at Michelob Ultra
Arena the game is sold out but there's a
big Fan Fest over at Mandalay Bay that's
open to everyone and we have the best of
the best out there for us right now
Candace Charles live at Mandalay Bay
with an inside look working on her jump
shot Candice good morning
I really have been working on my jump
shot John but unfortunately it didn't go
so well but I look like I'm ready for
the game and you guys can do the same
come on down here and enjoy and
experience with Fan Fest has to offer
WNBA live a second time they're having
and of course they gotta have right here
in Vegas because our aces are the
champions right and I have Phil cook
here with me from WNBA thank you so much
for joining us tell us a little bit
about what's going to happen here you
got a lot of things going on look our
partner Brands really stepped up so we
have we have uh eight hours today eight
hours tomorrow of of basketball of
culture of Music fashion design
customization food drink it's all
happening so the the culture in the
sport of basketball kind of colliding
right here WNBA live and this is really
built in spirit in the spirit of the
fans who are going to be down here
supporting the WNBA I love that this is
absolutely free as well let's talk a
little bit about the All-Star game
though sure what are we expecting from
that look All-Star games are notorious
for not being very competitive I think
the WNBA sets a bit of a different tone
I think these these women again these
are the best basketball players in the
world absolutely on a global stage
they're going to come in and bring it
this weekend and it's going to be a
competitive game I'm telling you it's
going to be a lot of fun to watch I
super excited Phil thank you so much for
joining us it sounds like it's going to
be a good time and like I said Fan Fest
has a lot to offer see we were going to
try to play a little game Rachel Moore
and I
I don't know if she's actually gonna
beat me so I'm just gonna toss it back
to you guys in the studio I want to get
embarrassed on here
oh my God yeah you got to keep them
separated
we'll we'll check it out on social media
yeah if you put it put it on Instagram
or something
all right 6 40